sa figure est également déployée au
darfour où l'eau angie va bientôt être
dans l'impossibilité de venir en aide à
un million de réfugiés
la lenteur de la réaction de la
communauté internationale face à la
catastrophe humanitaire annoncée dans
cette partie du monde décourage les
meilleures volontés et menace de
sanctions brandie par l'onu les états
unis et l'union européenne semblent ne
produire que peu d'effet sur le soudan
considéré comme principal responsable de
la crise david arnold la saison des
pluies commence dans quelques jours au
darfour
des torrents de boue rendront
l'acheminement des vivres aléatoire la
malaria
les diarrhées rempliront les hôpitaux la
mission des organisations militaires va
se compliquer
médecins sans frontières est sur place
depuis plusieurs mois et vous ça cri
d'alarmé
petit à petit on va voir des poches de
famine apparaître si on n'arrive pas à
nourrir toute cette population et il est
clair que la réaction tardive de la
communauté internationale du
gouvernement de khartoum
on râle entier quelque chose qui est une
machine dead avec une logistique très
lourde et qui aujourd'hui essayer de
donner une assistance pour ce million de
personnes ça va être très très difficile
dans les mois qui viennent msf n'a pas
constaté de véritable génocide pour eux
il n'y a pas eu de massacre systématique
de populations entières comme au rwanda
il ya dix ans mais selon les nations
unies près de cinquante mille personnes
seraient déjà morte
malgré les promesses du gouvernement
soudanais ces miliciens n'ont pas
désarmé
les cavaliers djandjawid ici à l'image
continue les violences à l'encontre des
peuples noirs nos fonds tissus les
rebelles
les etats-unis demandent des sanctions
des chenaux de nouvelles actions peuvent
être requises de la part de la
communauté internationale
et c'est pourquoi nous avons élaboré une
résolution pour le conseil de sécurité à
new york
la france privilégie pour l'instant la
voie du dialogue
michel barnier l'a rappelé hier
pour éviter une tragédie humanitaire on
ne le fera pas sans le suivant le
contrôle les états unis déposons cette
semaine leur résolution conseil de
sécurité mais le président soudanais a
déjà prévenu son peuple il s'agenouille
pas devant personne khartoum se dit prêt
à combattre toute ingérence étrangère